if I'm taking a [ __ ] do not talk to me
do not talk to me do not bother me with
anything it's all it you know people
have certain tree I yeah that will
trigger the [ __ ] out of really or and
this is trigger me it happened the other
day of my dad's in town I remember my
dad cook dinner a bike dinner's ready
you know and you'd like you're finishing
something up and then my dad will come
down my god yelled at and that used to
drive me enough my dad was over to my
house making dinner and goes I was doing
something goes hey Brent dinners on you
all right cool he goes hey let's go it's
hot like oh my house pop oh you're my
house Papa or sometimes my mother with
my mother I got really mad this weekend
I got really mad this week it's like
that my mom I love my mom but I got
actually inappropriately angry Haley
would you do well so there are couple
things my mother will do one is she
wants me about danger she'll find a
driver work but also this is there's
always this to watch order order a
sandwich what's this it's or in the
afternoon I'll take the chicken oh you
know we're easy in lesson three our pine
oh my god oh you I'm fifty two excuse me
I know what I need but that's a true
thing from when you were a kid
yeah then where does never ever go away
yeah but so so they never I don't know
how you make people look like I'm mad
about effort this is what I got mad
about when you are in Park City and your
parents live up on a hill hashtag money
you you have to drive up a wool road now
now there are it's a rural area so there
are deer everywhere I've never I've
never driven that route wherever you're
driving thirty miles an hour I've never
driven that route with my mother where
she hasn't said slow down you could hit
a deer and most importantly you might
hit a moose and you know you'll die if
you hit a moose but you can sue I know
but I let's never happen
have you ever happened and have you ever
been even close look dude there is two
moose there are two moons all of you
talk in that area but in all of you get
on the mountain yeah I guess they've
seen some moose twice there too that
they know of the dirt
those must have never been hit by a
[ __ ] card you know why cuz loose here
a car and they get away but apparently
sometimes you'll see the Moussa can't
hit there they're knocking like a moose
yeah and I'm going 30 or 25 miles now
they're size of a bus I got it yeah
there's that bus I got it so shouldn't
yelled it I'm not kidding every time I'm
not kidding
she goes be careful of the moose now my
daughter's in the car
my daughter was my caddy all weekend
wonderful weekend my daughter my
daughter my mother would be careful if
you could hit it we're talking about
[ __ ] something interesting I camera
yeah no is actually about Winston
Churchill on how terrible his childhood
woke it and it was really interesting
because he was sure but interrupted with
the she goes be careful of the moose you
could hit a moose and you know they're
black you don't see them until it's too
late
I do see them and I'm not gonna be
careful of a moose cuz I'm driving 20
miles and we're talking middle hey my
middle of the day I was at night my
darling daughter goes daddy be careful
of the moose now she's afraid and my
mother goes because he can kill you they
come right through no he said I'll kill
you yeah
my daughter's 11 she doesn't know she
goes daddy be careful and I'm like yeah
I'm not gonna be careful I'm daddy be
careful she was you should be careful
you're being stubborn I go I'm gonna
speed up now well now I find out the way
to speed up the 51 year old man probably
not the way to deal with 52 and I and I
it's triggered I was gonna help you I
know and I'm 31 and I go mmm
Danny starts to cry and I go stop crying
I'm not gonna hit a moose nobody's gonna
die for moose my mother oh you're an
ill-tempered you're an into ill tempered
Bratton this is exactly how you're the
moose I go I'm not gonna in a mouse it's
called your breath I got I got a quarter
mile to go and I'm not gonna miss the
chance anyone I'm freaking out how far
is it it's a giant LexA 4 flex it's a
it's a huge it has sensors so big and
Scott's dad said today anyway I lost my
[ __ ] mind and I started screaming
about the moose so it that carried on
put your hands on your my father my
father went like this as I'm yelling at
my mom and I continue the argument as my
mother goes you don't know you can't
listen no we never hit the moose there's
only two moose my daughter's now says
she's mad at me she said I go my
daughter's mad at me now and my father
looks at me and goes this
what I live with every day oh I was like
god damn it I don't know how you're rid
of those triggering things I have no
idea you know my father that's my dad uh
my father's been married to my mother
for 55 years goes away I can't find him
yeah he goes away right I know I can't
find him it's in the house and I hear
like there's a screen there's a big
screen we have this old screen right
here I go hello any good Hey
everyone has no no no are you hiding
behind the screen he visit your mother
keeps calling me I go I know we this
zone is beautiful I don't know yeah I
don't know how you ever get rid of those
triggering you can't yeah I don't think
you ever can oh these what'd he say
singers come on they talk what's going I
go I'd lose my mind a Papa here in my
husband just certain things it's hot
let's go oh man yeah I don't know if
like you do with it my father doesn't
kept trying to teach my son Italian
we're not telling you don't speak
Italian
hey Jeb going say ciao Tigers like what
he's fluent in Spanish in English she
say Chinese that could pick it up easily
but why because if he if he speaks three
like but you don't speak Italian so you
teach them child I don't know her well
you're wasting your time did my father
this is this is the one trigger I of my
father
because we played golf as a kid and he
would so I would I would i putt I don't
play golf dude I don't care
I play once a year with him I love
feeling yeah don't don't I don't care
don't go so I I so I putt and he'll go
like this I / putt and he'll go no you
slept it slapped halt man no he does
slapped at it bang hey you better shut
up man and then he was the same you know
what else old guys do that they I mean I
love my dad he's very very knowledgeable
on cars and sports but the old guys
don't fact-check anything so like I was
talking about a gt2 RS and this Aston
Martin and my dad goes you know I think
he's just like you know he doesn't know
he just be right heard someone else say
it's same thing we recurse date brighter
in the locker room with his other old
friends and he's
you know the gt2 RS is actually a
rougher ride than that than the gt3 r
it's that's not true it's actually a
rougher ride and I just don't think you
won't even fit you won't fit oh well no
that's not true
and then we getting the beat just right
away I'm like hold on no no no look I
look at my phone I just actually bring
up the review I can bring it up dude
there's no more bro science in that
finally kid this bro science we spit
yeah but in when it comes to fact my
mine well the one thing about my father
is he's he's so [ __ ] thorough with
his facts
he's so thorough my mother is not my
mother goes by intuition my mother
walked by me the other day nothing
drives me crazy because she finds cancer
everywhere and she'll just go she walked
by she goes um hey your stomach is not a
normal shape lately that stuff I go
that's not that's categorically untrue
she goes well something's not enormous
there walks out you know she said though
your mom asked for 15 tickets next
weekend you gotta give it to him nope no
I went mom no one has money yeah I give
to you yeah in the family but I went
where they taught you well my friends at
work or family Oh mom come on yeah fifty
you know my mom and my father at their
80 now you know they're both very
healthy thank God I don't know but at 80
they said you know we just keep looking
around and all our friends start dying
or they have they get some crazy yeah
but um what's interesting is that my
mother said I don't think being skinny
helps you in the long run and I went
what do mean she goes I did this Talley
about all our friends they every one of
her friends worked out and stays super
thin their whole life they all get
something bad they all just died or 80
every single one of them like they uh I
mean I don't think that's a scientific
study but it was working sometimes it
though you'll be like I agree come on
but but though the ones that are really
skinny like especially the joggers
especially the ones that do a lot of
long-distance running apparently just
you know [ __ ] mmm maybe it's some for
your mom's friends yeah it's not a
scientific study
I wonder though do your parents have to
get stronger if joggers little mormon
what triggers you it's oh it always has
to do with my weight cuz I was always
the chubby one of my family do you were
you affect your not heavy I always I was
chubby for the Mike the group of my
cousins that I grew up with but I got
your thick like curvy chubby like chubby
like eight like little Asian baby chubby
[ __ ] yeah
like I was always like a smaller kid
because I was Asian and I'm just
genetically smaller but amongst my
cousins I was always the chubby r1 and
every single time I gained any weight
they make it seem like I don't notice it
myself they're like hey you know you
gain where I'm like fat shaming work I'm
like yes I I know do you not think I
look in the mirror every single day do
you not think I'm gonna make sure it
doesn't make me self-conscious I just
don't like that they bring it up all the
time and they bring it up as if I don't
know do me a favor to give you a complex
growing up with it yes oh my gosh yes
what happened whatever you're doing you
I think you look fantastic I think you
look adorable timepi yeah you look are
you working out still you're doing all
right yeah I'm working out a guy who
couldn't look better I think you right
she looks amazing this right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]